oh man Louis I am fired up we have a
hell of a show today and I know that
there is going to be a portion of our
audience that is not going to like me
after today's show but you know what I
know that there is a portion of our
audience that is going to appreciate
that I am NOT doing things or not doing
things for optics on the program and i
am telling it to you like i see it and
like I think it's important for
progressives to know what am I talking
about well last week I talked to you
about a whole bunch of people emailing
me saying David are you voting for Jill
Stein the green party candidate because
if you supported Bernie the obvious
correct thing is obviously to support
jill stein and I explained no I'm not
Jill Stein is fundamentally anti-science
on a number of issues including GMO she
is irrationally anti-israeli in a way
that I could never ever get behind
because no sensible rational person
could ever come to the conclusion she
has come to on that issue and it's
gotten way way worse really really bad a
video was sent to me of jill stein
saying that Wi-Fi could be dangerous for
our brains and i'm gonna play the clip
for you it's actually not clear from the
clip that she knows the difference
between Wi-Fi and wireless phones it is
just an utter mess okay first Jill Stein
says and I'll play it for you that
education should move away from screens
that that that wishes should not have
kids on screens in school which we could
talk about screen usage but if you want
students to be ready for college and the
real world you need a reasonable amount
of computer work to be going on we'll
listen to that and then we'll get to the
Wi-Fi part and it is just this is just
flat-out anti-science stuff the stuff of
uh of of conspiracy websites okay take a
look wonderful um health issues social
issues you know you name it but to be
staring at screens you know I mean we
already know that kids who get put in
front of TVs you know instead of
interacting this is not good in all
kinds of ways and is just it's it's not
good for their cognitive development
it's not good for their social
development
I mean that is incredible that kids in
kindergarten we should be moving away
from screens at all levels of education
not moving into them yeah and this is
another corporate ruse you know this is
another gimmick to try to make make a
buck make big bucks in fact and
education and teachers and communities
suffer so we need to stand up to that
thank you yes right I mean we should not
be subjecting um kids brains especially
to that and you know we don't follow
that issue in this country but in in
Europe where they do you know they're
they have good precautions around
wireless maybe not good enough you know
because it's very hard to study this
stuff you know we make guinea pigs out
of whole populations and then we
discover how many died you know and this
is like the paradigm for how public
health works in this country and it's
outrageous you know I mean this is why
we need to take back really not just our
schools you know and and our electoral
system here we really need to take back
the whole institution of how we this is
whoo okay this is not a thinking
progressive and it's not even clear she
knows what she's talking about the
question seems to be about Wi-Fi and
there are completely unsubstantiated
claims that Wi-Fi could cause cancer
that the radiation is bad for brains
etcetera we know about wireless phones
and I don't know if the critique here
because I don't understand exactly is
the critique that she's saying there is
there is something to Wi-Fi and brains
or is she just not understanding the
difference between Wi-Fi and mobile
phones I don't know but it is a
non-science mess Wi-Fi has been studied
there is no reasonable evidence at all
that it poses any risk to health and the
articles keep getting posted in you
might read headlines on YouTube about
Wi-Fi and health but there is no good
science saying Wi-Fi is bad for people
it has been studied and it comes down
Louis to understanding types of
radiation not getting out not worth
getting into now but this is non science
mumbo-jumbo there is nothing to this
yeah it's uh the getting away from
screens thing that kind of irritate
it's me as as well it's uh yeah but it's
easy to fall into that trap she's she's
in that camp it's easy to do a cursory
Internet's reason yeah search of jill
stein say oh yeah she seems pretty
level-headed and i like what she stands
for but uh there are some serious
concerns here there's also been serious
debate about Jule Stynes position on
vaccines and the debate has been because
she's previously taken a pretty nebulous
stance about it The Washington Post
finally got Jill Stein to be more direct
about her stance on vaccines and it is
disturbing she started off fine talking
about the importance of vaccines I'll
put up the first quote for you here
where she says they think there's no
question vaccines have been critical in
ridding us of the scourge of many
diseases etcetera etcetera etcetera the
problem though is that people do not
trust the Food and Drug Administration
or even CDC for that matter where
corporate and pharmaceutical influence
where corporate influence in the
pharmaceutical industry have a lot of
influence okay fair enough and then
here's where it goes completely non
science whoo mumbo-jumbo where she
continues and says as a medical doctor
and now this is really low because her
experience as a medical doctor has no
bearing on any of what she's talking
about with regard to vaccines but she
says as a medical doctor there was a
time where I looked very closely it does
those issues and not all those issues
were completely resolved there were
concerns among physicians about what the
vaccination schedule meant the toxic
substances like mercury which used to be
rampant in vaccines there were real
questions that needed to be addressed I
think some of them at least have been
addressed I don't know if all of them
have been addressed and you might say
well no big deal she sort of dancing
around the whole mercury toxicity
vaccine schedule thing she's using her
title of doctor to appear to be
particularly qualified to comment about
vaccines when she's not the mercury
thing has been totally debunked and if
you're going to email me and I know some
of you will and say well David Snope
said Jill Stein is right on vaccines
number one no one source is ever always
right so yes snopes wrote an article
defending Jill Stein but four or five
other reputable skeptic pro-science
blogs have said we'll listen both jill
stein and snopes are wrong on this so
Louis this is not someone
that I would ever support and I have
disagreements with Hillary Clinton on
specific elements of foreign policy or i
would rather the minimum wage be 15
rather than twelve dollars or whatever
but this is just fundamentally
anti-science nonsense and i'll mention
also the Green Party supports funding
homeopathy which has been debunked as
not a valid treatment or cure for any
conditioner symptom period homeopathy is
nothing and the Green Party not
necessarily junt Jill Stein but the
Green Party supports funding that I
don't want anything to do with this now
at the party should really be focusing
more on there what they should really
they should sound like Bernie Sanders
yeah uh they really need to get away
from this stuff and you know it's just
as easy to do a cursory search of
Hillary Clinton and think that
everything's wonderful uh and then you
add to this the the reality that Jill
Stein cannot and will not be the
president uh just add that into your
equation I know it's great have no other
parties but just consider that we also
need to add into the equation when we
talk about Jill Stein that she is chosen
a running mate for vice president who is
a total extremist if you regularly watch
or listen to this show you know this is
not a show where I will cheerlead
anything that has a supposedly
progressive stamp on it if you want the
show like that there are many shows like
that okay I don't even need to name them
for you you can find those i am going to
be completely upfront that when there is
a critique I need to make of something
that is supposedly progressive I will
make it and Jill Stein has chosen a
jammu Baraka as her running mate for the
presidency on the Green Party ticket
we've already talked about Jill Stein's
anti-science views the Green Party's pro
homeopathy views okay fine what about a
John Woo Baraka well he's written that
President Obama and other members of the
black petite bourgeoisie uh are merely
puppets living proof that the white
supremacist machine has hijacked the
minds of black people okay also wrote an
article on his blog titled Paris attacks
and the white lives matter movement
where he argues that France Belgium and
other nations that have been affected by
terrorism effectively got what they
deserved saying while the victims of the
violence in Paris may have been innocent
France
as not he wrote because the crimes
committed against Arabs Muslims and
Africans and the horrors of colonialism
and the concerted effort by the French
and US authorities to fund extremist
groups in the Middle East are to blame
for the woes of Western societies
according to Baraka the Sanders campaign
didn't offer a genuine program for
radical change I mean that we're talking
about free education uh government
provided healthcare that apparently was
not radical enough because it was
tacitly committed to Eurocentrism and as
he says the Bernie Sanders campaign
normalized white supremacy he's written
on his blog that Syrian leader Bashar
al-assad isn't a bad guy who was after
all reelected by big margins and that he
is not engaged in any war crimes against
his people demonstrably untrue he went
on Kevin Barrett's truth jihad podcast
is basically a 911 truth or podcast and
said that but the some recent airline
crashes were false flags that the
Democratic Party is white supremacist
and he is also saying that the u.s. is
intentionally supporting Isis now we've
talked about how weapons get two groups
that the u.s. claims to oppose but the
flat out say the u.s. is flat-out
supporting Isis is a bit further than
most rational clear thinkers are willing
to go if this is the liberal hero of the
supposedly miraculous Green Party Louis
I want nothing to do with it this is an
extremist you would never think that he
would be part of the Green Party in any
way right free if you just read what he
was about unbelievable at maybe he was
just picked because Jill Stein no she's
not going to win but this is someone who
maybe could get her uh more votes votes
she might not otherwise have okay who
does this guy really appeal to that's
what I'm trying to figure out anybody
who truly analyzes what this individual
has written and said and identifies as a
progressive there's a fundamental clash
there I don't know how you could say I
am a true progressive and after reading
what ujamaa Baraka has read and said
over time
that's who I want to support I don't get
it so you all know I voted for Bernie
Sanders and you all know very clearly
that I am NOT supporting the stein
Baraka ticket in November uh bring on
the hate tell me where I am wrong we
will take a break yesterday a really big
deal was made about a quote major Donald
Trump economic policy speech now I was
shocked because basically every Trump
speech is him reading polling numbers
insulting people and using words like
tremendous and terrific over and over
again but no this was billed as a major
economic policy speech sadly it was just
a disjointed combination of myths lies
and bogus ideas let's go through a few
of them and I'll put a list up for those
of you that are watching along with me
to begin with Trump started with the the
normal labor force participation
conspiracy suggesting that the
unemployment rate is actually somewhere
between 21 and forty-two percent we've
debunked this many many times he's
including retired people in there he's
including junior and senior high school
students who are not working he's
including parents who are choosing to
stay at home he's including people who
opted to work part-time that's a totally
debunked conspiracy theory Trump also
claimed that former Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton has proposed quote one
of the biggest ever tax increases which
he said would target middle-class
Americans actually Hillary Clinton
hasn't proposed that but there's I wish
I had more to debunk that but she just
hasn't proposed that Trump also promised
that he would repeal quote disastrous
Obamacare saving another two million
American jobs well that's a common
Obamacare myth uh oh bah macaire is not
going to be repealed Obamacare has not
killed jobs we are in the middle of one
of the biggest private sector job growth
periods on record for decades uh so that
is absolutely bogus Donald Trump also
claimed that the US has the highest
business tax rate among the major
industrialized nations of the world at
thirty five percent which he would slash
to no more than fifteen percent will
turns out
the effective tax rate is already 12
point six percent it is true that on
paper the top marginal corporate tax
rate for the biggest businesses is
thirty-five percent but you know and I
know and Louis knows and most of the
people listening know very few
businesses actually pay that you
consider tax credits other mechanisms
offshoring etcetera etcetera 12.6
percent is actually the effective tax
rate paid that's not high at all Trump
also saying Hillary would tax some small
businesses by as much as nearly fifty
percent but nothing in her plan says
that she would do that Trump also saying
he would eliminate the death tax aka the
estate tax you might not know this louis
but the estate tax already exempt its
estates up to five million dollars there
are fewer than one in five hundred
americans who even are subject to that
tax because 499 out of five hundred
americans don't have a states that are
five million dollars Trump would
increase that exemption to 10.9 million
dollars real fighter for the middle
class huh and lastly he would put a
moratorium on all new government
regulations I mean that's just
ridiculous Louis if there are
regulations that are needed regulations
are needed saying you're just going to
not do any regulation is bogus
absolutely nothing here coherent or
based in fact the funniest one is is
moratorium on government regulations how
does that mean yeah i mean what all of a
sudden uh when drones are flying through
the air with okay no no regulations even
though we have this new thing happening
uh we'll just let the the chaos ensue
yeah absolutely no changes at all the
government will not get involved in
anything period now if you knew about
Trump's so-called economic team you
probably wouldn't be surprised that it's
essentially gibberish that came out of
this quote major economic speech Trump's
so-called economic advisors are
basically a microcosm of his campaign
his 13-person economic advisory team is
all male and has very few economist so
as usual it's yet another boys club with
no experts on the subject matter
representative of the broader problems
in Trump's campaign
and chances are they they are
incompetent because that also seems to
be a theme throughout his uh with his
campaign staff everything is opposite
with Donald Trump one of his big sales
pitches about himself is I'm gonna put
the best people around me when I don't
know i will put the best people around
me uh and then he comes up with
spokespeople healy Baumgardner and
Katrina Pearson who say they don't
actually speak on behalf of Donald Trump
well you've been hired as a spokesperson
so I thought you did and can't put
together a coherent argument on any
national news outlets oh yeah the entire
i'll put the best people around me thing
not really making sense okay we have to
talk about this new narrative that is
being created by Trump supporters that
all the polls are fabricated and skewed
towards Hillary Clinton yesterday I told
you that Hillary Clinton is now leading
16 of the latest 16 polls nationally of
the presidential election and every time
we do this I get emails from people
saying David don't you see what's going
on the liberal media is skewing the
polls to make it seem as though Hillary
is waiting now not only do we have no
evidence of that wouldn't that be kind
of stupid Louis because if you want
Hillary to win skewing the polls to make
it look like she is winning actually
puts at risk that Hillary voters will
stay home thinking she doesn't need
their vote it's a very dumb strategy if
that's what you're trying to do yeah I I
don't see and I don't see how it would
be beneficial to those who are doing the
polling and put this information out
doesn't make any sense and nate silver
wrote an article i'm sorry/not nate
silver on nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com this morning an
article was written by one of the other
staff writers basically debunking what
is being used as the explanation for why
these polls are biased and what a lot of
right-wingers including the queen of the
birther movement orly taitz i'm on her
mailing list only because i can't
unsubscribe i've tried to get our
mailing list a dozen times you can't do
it you just can't do it so I get her
mailings she is critical of some of
these polls by saying Democrats are
oversampled if you look at the
percentage of people in the poll that
are Democrats it's way higher than the
number of
kratz that are actually registered and
what is not understood by people like
the queen of the birther movement or
orly taitz is that the pollsters don't
weigh the results by party
self-identification and what many people
don't know is in the polls they're often
as which party do you identify with this
is often different than actual party
registration and this little detail
seems lost on many people like orly
taitz they're being asked which party do
you identify with oh I identify as an
independent I identify as a Democrat
this is very different than how people
are registered and Kentucky is a really
good example Kentucky has way more
democratic registered voters the sort of
Dixiecrat Blue Dogs etcetera but when
you actually look at how people vote it
is much more conservative and
fivethirtyeight.com does a really good
job of explaining how you can't just
look at a poll and co they have
thirty-seven percent Democrats even
though democratic registration is
thirty-two percent or whatever it is it
really doesn't tell you the story when
you consider identification and
registration are very different things
yeah and and and what would be the
motivation and how would fabricating
polls yeah uh help these pollsters in
the future it just really doesn't make
any sense there's no reason to do it
they're there just is no reasonable
reason why you would do that and there
are repercussions when pollsters are
really wrong right there are posters
from the twenty twelve election who were
just way off and they're no longer
included in averages of poles
RealClearPolitics for example does an
average of polls to give you an overall
picture of how things look they decide
which pollsters to include based on
track record and there's really no
advantage to just making up polls there
really is not this is not the onion
version of the david pakman show this is
a real story republican presidential
nominee Donald Trump suggested the
possibility that gun owners use their
guns against Hillary Clinton if she is
indeed elected in November this was at a
campaign rally yesterday in Wilmington
North Carolina you would think it was a
fake story you would
yeah the guy mark the disabled reporter
yeah the guy ridiculed the gold star
family whose son was killed in 2004 a
fighting for the US military yeah the
guy suggests unconstitutional immoral
and unconscionable ideas all the time
but he wouldn't hint that his supporters
could maybe kill his opponent would he
yes he would take a look Hilary wants to
abolish essentially abolish the Second
Amendment by the way and she gets to
pick if she gets to pick her judges
nothing you can do folks although the
Second Amendment people may be there is
I don't know but what I'll tell you what
that will be a horrible day hey guys any
day now Trump is going to pivot to a
softer more conciliatory tone
conciliatory tone just after he ends
with the suggestions of killing
political opponents he's really
resetting his campaign in an amazing way
shift away from the Muslim ban towards
killing your opponent even the Trump
supporter on stage there's a guy who all
point to if you're watching this guy
right here with the red shirt this guy
right here he looks stunned when Donald
Trump says this i'ma just replay a few
seconds of the Trump statement zoomed in
on this guy even the guy pick to be on
stage at a trump rally and you've gotta
be out of your mind in favor of Trump to
make it onto the stage at a rally he's
shocked take a look although the Second
Amendment people maybe there is a butt
but I'll tell you why that will be a
horrible day there is one other possibly
by the way unclear actually whether he's
shocked they're thrilled and and until
ated by the by the suggestion there's
also the possibility that Trump was
suggesting not killing Hillary Clinton
but killing the judges that Hillary
Clinton would appoint way different you
know I guess advocating the mass murder
uh as opposed to just a single
assassination is a little bit different
it's uh it's not really now it's the
same what we're talking about is just
killing your political opponents and uh
yeah it's uh not going to change a thing
though for his is a staunch supporter
now if you're a supporter of Trumpy what
he already said I
two people on Fifth Avenue couldn't
wouldn't change anything really true if
he suggesting other people shoot someone
why would that change anything now the
campaign has said oh all he was doing
was trying to activate voters to vote in
November for whom the Second Amendment
is important no the entire thing was if
Hillary wins in November then XYZ will
happen if you're talking about something
that will happen if Hillary wins after
the election and what people might do
you can't then say what I was actually
doing was trying to encourage people to
vote now this is a good time for me to
introduce or reintroduce the term
stochastic terrorism now stochastic is a
term that's often used in investing
right in stocks it sort of means
randomly determined having a random
probability but distribution or pattern
which we could analyze statistically but
we couldn't predict precisely so like
for example if I said to you x percent
of stocks statistically and
probabilistic ly speaking over the next
10 years will go up by two thousand
percent right we know that some stocks
probably will but we have really no way
of predicting exactly which stocks those
are it applies to what Donald Trump is
doing in that the general suggestion of
using guns against Hillary Clinton or
against her Supreme Court nominees or
whoever statistically speaking because
of the size of trumps platform it could
well lead to someone being inspired by
what he said to actually go and kill a
judge or try to kill Hillary Clinton
hopefully the Secret Service would be
would be able to protect her but it's
completely unpredictable who it would be
but once you get to large enough numbers
these are not words that have no meaning
and that's how the term stochastic
terrorism applies here Louis we know
that Trump's rhetoric months ago uh the
the the semi tone down rhetoric back
then was enough to lead people to
beating up our black people at Trump
rallies yeah so imagine what this type
of of rhetoric can do I wasn't imagining
that within two weeks those horrible
comments about gold star dad kazakh on
and deceased army captain who mayan con
would seem relatively innocuous as
offensive as they were but we kinda have
to hand it to trump louis he's come up
with
something so much more outrageous that
the entire Khan scandal seems relatively
tame compared to the UH implicit
suggestion that you kill his opponent he
he steps it up every week every week he
says something more outrageous than than
the week before and I'm wondering where
he hits the wall right where does this
end our supporters ready to stop saying
well Trump didn't really mean it when he
says ban Muslims he's he just kind of
saying it it's not really anything that
will have an impact what's Paul Ryan
going to say now while I don't agree
with Trump suggesting his supporters
assassinate Hillary Clinton I still
support him in our party as the
Republican nominee this is a campaign in
chaos and imagine being Secret Service
you're paid to protect both candidates
and one is making comments that could
endanger the other it is a very very
weird time to be following politics and
we will talk to Bill share about it a
little bit later let's talk about a
story involving WikiLeaks and Julian
Assange up on July eighth just over a
month ago twenty-seven-year-old
Democratic staffer Seth rich was
murdered in Washington DC now it was
initially described as an attempted
robbery gone wrong but some disagree
with that because the killer or killers
left behind riches wallet his watch and
his phone and if the goal was to rob him
you would think that after killing him
they would have at least taken his stuff
although maybe not if they left in some
kind of panic uh Seth riches father said
to reporters if it was a robbery it
failed because he still has his watch
his money and his credit cards Julian
Assange did an interview yesterday with
Swedish television suggesting implying
that Seth rich was now I don't I want to
be careful here maybe a WikiLeaks
informant or the WikiLeaks informant
around the leak DNC emails not Russia I
will play the video for you and people
are coming away with basically one
impression which is honestly or
dishonestly because it's true or because
of some kind of message that Julian
Assange wants to put in the media
discussion he is implying that Seth rich
was WikiLeaks its source on the DNC
email
take a look Donald Trump has had a
disastrous few weeks if you look at the
polls he needs a miracle in the American
political lexicon there's such a thing
as the October Surprise the stuff that
you're sitting on is is an october
surprise in there we even know what
you're sitting on WikiLeaks never sits
on material whistleblowers go to
significant efforts to get us material
and often very significant risks as a 27
year old I works for the DNC who shot in
the back murdered just two weeks ago
from unknown reasons as he was walking
down the street in Washington so that
was just a rubbery I'd leaf wasn't it no
that's there's no finding so what are
you doing what are you suggesting I'm
suggesting that our sources are take
risks and they are they become concerned
to see things occurring like that but
was he one of your sources then I mean
we don't comment on who our sources I
make the suggestion about a young guy
being shot in the streets of Washington
because that we have to understand uh
how high the stakes are in the United
States shortly after this interview
WikiLeaks announced that they were
offering a twenty-thousand-dollar reward
for information leading to a conviction
in the killing of Seth rich now there is
a faction that believes Julian Assange
is knowingly or unknowingly wittingly or
unwittingly being manipulated by Russia
or maybe even the Trump campaign to hurt
Hillary Clinton now one piece of
evidence people point to is that Roger
stone this huge Trump supporter recently
claimed to be in touch with Julian
Assange just two days ago speaking to
the south west broward republican
organization Roger stone said the
following take a look regard to the
October Surprise which would be your
forecast
given what Julian Assange has intimated
going to do well it could be any number
of things I actually have uh
communicated with Assange uh i believe
the next crunches documents pertaining
to the clinton foundation but there's no
telling what the October Surprise may be
why on earth would Roger stone be in
touch with Julian Assange but stone is a
known liar and implying something you
know to be false is also a tactic to
create drama the other issue is Julian
Assange could be contradicting himself
because he has said many times Louis
that the WikiLeaks submission system is
by definition anonymous so that even
WikiLeaks themselves often have no way
of knowing who sent them information or
identifying where leaks came from uh I I
honestly do not know what to think I am
presenting this at first it was just
conspiracy theories that Seth rich was
killed in some kind of cover-up
retribution or proactive killing to
prevent him from spilling the beans on
something he knew I didn't find it
worthwhile of coverage at that point now
that Julian Assange is saying this it
changes the dynamic of the story
drastically uh I'm I'm kind of thinking
that this is not a connection he would
draw if uh if he didn't at least believe
that there was some connection there
even if he doesn't necessarily no rights
uh he doesn't seem like the type of guy
to just drop something like that um and
knowing that it's it's false or not
having any other information or just or
just throwing it out there because it's
salacious uh uh but I could be wrong I
really don't know if he is indeed
throwing this out there to create drama
or because it is salacious or to get
attention which I i agree doesn't
particularly strike me like Julian
Assange is mo it would be hugely
irresponsible and unethical we will
follow this and we will see where it
ultimately goes let's take a quick break
plenty more after this okay Donald Trump
is not stopping the UH continued I don't
know penchant for obsession with making
completely ridiculous and baseless
comments and
latest after I guess attempting to reset
his campaign by suggesting his
supporters kill Hillary Clinton his
latest accusation is that President
Barack Obama is actually the founder of
Isis now I know Louis you didn't know
that I didn't know that many in our
audience would be surprised to hear wait
a second Obama founded Isis but that is
exactly what Donald Trump said last
night at of another one of these
completely laughable rallies where he
shows up looking a very strange shade of
orange with but bizarre notes and just
making statements that don't make sense
let's take a look at the video de say
Isis is honoring President Obama he is
the founder of Isis he's the founder of
Isis yeah okay he's the founder
he founded Isis and I would say the
co-founder would be crooked Hillary
Clinton right that immediately was met
with chance of lock her up by the crowd
did you notice Louis that it you can
actually see in the picture that's over
my shoulder this is not a lot of people
here and of course people on stage are
pretty pretty carefully selected right
here you will notice a black woman and
right here you will notice a black man
as we know Trump polling 0% among black
people statistically in some states like
Ohio uh talk about pandering huh well I
can tell you he doesn't look happy to be
there his facial expression and uh he
probably thought I'll just get paid to
do this because no one else will and
I'll sit here and I'll deal with this
and listen to trump uh no actual
evidence though that the people on stage
were being paid to Lewis is being
facetious we don't want to be accused
Lewis of suggesting those people were
paid they melt may well have been but we
just have no evidence to support I'm
just assuming that he was paid to be
there uh so so what is Trump suggesting
that the foreign policy decisions of
Barack Obama created Isis I guess that's
the sort of point because i would say
that in that case George Bush is the
founder of Isis I I was gonna get to
that right because this is number one
this is not the first time that Trump is
connected Obama to Isis a couple of
months ago he tweeted an article from
right wing news website Breitbart which
said the Obama administration was
actively support supporting al-qaeda in
Iraq the terrorist group that became the
Islamic state so Donald Trump is
implying as Louis says that the foreign
policy decisions of President Obama and
Hillary Clinton as President Obama
Secretary of State somehow created the
conditions or maybe even more directly
led to the creation of Isis of course
reasonable scholars a foreign policy and
reality as opposed to fantasy worlds
understand that the real single decision
that created a vacuum in the area that
led to the creation of Isis was george w
bush's harebrained decision to go into
Iraq in 2003 based on the false pretense
that number one
Iraq had weapons of mass destruction and
number two there was some connection
between Iraq and the 911 attacks I've
said it before and I will say it again
if you support Donald Trump you were
either ignorant unstable or a genuinely
bad person but as I see this day after
day after day ice I do start to question
the broader intelligence or lack thereof
of the US as a nation and this isn't
sort of a comment Louis about individual
people but it's sort of about this
entire country because although
individuals voted for Donald Trump
somehow we've gotten to a place in the
United States of America in 2016 where
someone like Trump can even become the
nominee who still present essentially no
policy positions at these speeches and
says things like Obama founded Isis and
what about killing Hillary yeah III you
look at his supporters and I think we
all know that most countries all
countries are full of racist people
that's never going to change that just
up appealing to to xenophobic people is
is pretty easy to do uh but let's face
it our education system is not that
great uh compared to other countries at
our level of development and that's what
that's what you get attribute I
attribute a lot to our education system
and just generally two decades and
decades of of uh corporations buying
politicians and and I mean when that
happens it just it's your your country
just crumbles to sum up Donald Trump has
worked out how he will defeat Isis as
president but it's sort of a secret
until he's elected you know because of
national security and stuff but he's
gonna somehow do it without sending in
any US troops because he was always
against the iraq war and would never do
that although we know that he actually
told howard stern in 2002 he was in
favor of the iraq war but he never
mentions that so I've actually put
together a sort of policy guide for what
it is that Donald Trump's plan for the
Middle East is it and we've had to infer
some of this so number one trumpet said
he's against intervention in the Middle
East he has also said that forcing
regime change is bad in overthrowing uh
Gaddafi was bad although he is on record
in 2011 is having said that he's in
favor of over
gaddafi so a little bit of a conflict
there he's also said the Iraq war was
bad and that he never supported it
that's also a lie he told Howard Stern
in 2002 he's in favor of it and of
course we know that he will kill and
torture terrorists as well as their
families up but he's against
intervention in the Middle East and
lastly according to Joe Scarborough
based on a conversation he had with
someone who was in the room with Trump
during a foreign policy briefing Trump
is not quite clear on why we can't just
use nuclear weapons to solve all of
these problems to begin with so I can't
make heads or tails out of it Louis is
where I come away yeah it's uh he
doesn't have a plan he said before he's
going to get the best people so far he's
collected the worst people yeah maybe
it's easier to collect good people once
you're actually president shore and and
maybe they think Trump just isn't very
legitimate now pretty scary that he he
could be quite legitimate as as soon as
he's commander-in-chief none of this
stuff appeals to the Republicans who are
just more concerned with smaller
government and lower taxes and they
don't really like liberal politicians
right just because you don't like Obama
doesn't mean you think Obama created the
Islamic state and Donald Trump although
you would imagine he's trying to pivot
to appeal to more people in the
electorate the idea that maybe Hillary
should be killed or her just judges
should be killed the people she would
pick or that Obama founded the Islamic
state it's actually appealing to a
narrow and narrow narrower and narrower
group of American voters and we're
seeing that reflected in the polls if
I'm wrong about any of this let me know
i'm on twitter at d pakman